c'est un truc de ouf les chéris puisque
ça y est il est arrivé ça n'est pas le
beaujolais c'est le nouvel iphone oms il
a été présenté
et ouais les gars ça y est les gars
juste un petit problème
gd fléchi s'ils écoutent 1600 euros le
bol euros l'harmattan ça le gros des
gens m'a jamais parlé comme ça mais je
n'avais joué dans 1600 euros ah non mais
sans déconner aujourd'hui pour acheter
un téléphone frère tu dois faire un
emprunt sur trente ans ça veut dire
c'est plus fluide le semis de maïs et
des voitures à ce prix là mais combien
ça bien sûr mais il est bloqué à lui 600
premières voitures
j'ai payé 2003 saignant ciel et dernière
liste et non pas la dernière voiture
j'ai pas de voiture en ce moment chez
koti net et falgarde que je vous roule
pas sur la gueule
ce qu'ils annoncent des trucs de ouf ça
veut dire les annonces des nouveautés tu
dois changer ta vie
alors les nouveautés genre c'est le slow
fille c'est à dire que tu peux faire des
scènes filmées au ralenti
j'aimerais vraiment 1500 balcon faire dé
7,0 ralenti non mais sans déconner il ya
un autre truc c'est la nouvelle batterie
elle dure une journée entière c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui tu poses plus de bien à
charge et au téléphone qui a parlé de
grand voile non mais ça y est tu parles
à chaque fois tu étais toujours en
angoisse quand tu sais que tu vas être
coupée à tout moment moi et moi je vous
dire moi c'est un gros problème
même au niveau des délais ddd 10,2 du
sexe féminin mais que ses succès passés
un peu tu peux te couper à tout moment
les gens noirs il faut lui adjoindre à
des batteries externes
j'ai aucune batterie externe ni dans mon
corps ni dans mon portable je vous le
dis et géraldine maillet qui compte
lâche t il est la vérité non matthieu
delormeau
voilà exactement c'est la richesse jours
après qu'il a produit et bouffe sur nrj
vous allez ainsi c'est pas ça c'est que
quand on est quelqu'un de connu on doit
aussi faire rêver ce moment vous parlez
de qui là ouais mais de moi donc je
devrai d'abord c'est pour être connecté
avec les fans et puis oui parce que
c'est on doit faire rêver on doit être
beau à voir des beaux objets je peux pas
me permettre d'être moche je peux pas me
permettre des prises au jeu représente
une part une partie de la france une
partie de ces 8es je fais rêver des gens
alors battez vous d'ici là on vient de
me dire un truc pour présenter
maintenant qu'une partie de la france je
ne fais plus partie de ces donc ça c'est
réglé
oui ma mini en fait il est en train de
chercher qui veut lui offrir un voile et
moi ça m'intéresse pas du tout ainsi et
tais toi
non mais juste deux minutes vous êtes
faits portent pas un chien là non mais
ça c'est des épaules aux c'est vous êtes
pris vous n'êtes pas très sexy prêts
structurés alors il ya un autre truc et
tient 30 minutes sous l'eau à deux
mètres de profondeur
génial non mais tu crois tu vas vraiment
appeler des gens ça tombe dans l'eau
quand c'est la faute aux toilettes mon
iphone il tombe est tout le temps dans
les toilettes il avait deux problèmes ou
bien tomber dans l'état est non mais tu
es dans ta poche tu vois chaque tombe
dedans le nom et les fans m'attendent à
toi toi vous avez des toilettes turques
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quand tu mets ton dans les annales
épaulettes et tranquillement il est 9h
au csad foisonnent rôle dominant tapote
ouais parce qu'on dit derrière
non d'abord jeu derrière tu es une fille
de bruce baisse ton pantalon éclater sa
tombe je sais pas mais ça décèle
isabelle salutaire avec son minitel
l'ambiance était là j'ai un truc dont on
a dit oui c'est vrai mais c'est me
croyait pas si bien dire
éric et hugo tél je suis jamais servi
mais comme nous on est en open space à
airtel
donc on va souvent de téléphoner aux
toilettes pour s'isoler balle hors jeu
peut prévenir josé spectateurs attention
cette anecdote risque de choquer des
gens je ne la connais pas mais je ne la
sens pas du tout voilà qui pense qu'il
va y avoir une chute à son anecdote non
non non allez on pense qu'il va pas en
avoir
ah bah oui c'est parti eh ben dis donc
j'étais effectivement aux toilettes une
fois que mon coup de fil a été terminée
je me suis levé le téléphone est tombé
dans les toilettes est parti tout de
suite au fond et c'est là j'ai jamais
été aussi content de ma vie d'être très
constipé moi je veux
[Musique]
s'il y avait une chose c'est que les
chiffres ont tous les quarts d'heure est
emmerdé moi non ouais merci
il fait en tout cas un très très bon
début d vraiment vous vraiment bravo oui
moi j'ai perdu mon portable au concert
des cuivres ou non et alors en fait
j'étais avec des potes et j'ai vu me
faufiler pour aller voir de très près
donc j'ai poussé des gens et ou amender
un mouvement de foule il y avait un
monsieur très
et oui barack est devant moi je me suis
accroché à son sac à dos donc j'avais
les pieds touchent et plus sale et en
fait il est tombé
mon portable est tombé je me suis fait
repêcher par le monsieur de la sécu il
m'a tendu ma levée en l'air comme ça je
suis arrivé sur un un roulant et en fait
je suis parti donc j'ai vécu au moins à
deux mètres j'étais trop contente mais a
prêché années plus tard table d'accord
est ce que vous trouvez pas que les
histoires de portable sans que tu veux
vous voyez bien c'est un calcul jones
était lancé un matin alors on rappelle
que vous êtes allé chez elton john
oui mais là on n'a rien vu que elton
john quand vous arrivez chez lui il vous
demande de laisser votre portable à
l'entrée absolument c'est incroyable non
mais c'est normal il veut pas qu'on
filme des choses tout ça ça paraît
normal mais j'ai demandé de l'autre côté
comprennent aussi sans portable qui me
filme pas non plus mais sarah star ya
pas de raison qu'il y ait un john
matthieu delormeau aujourd'hui c'est la
can
on était spectateur en tout cas c'est
lui qui vous a prêté votre styliste
c'est joli non
besson va très bien elle est de très
courte à l'époque je rappelle que c'est
fini à l'époque où j'étais qu'aucun la
période coquine la période vilaine c'est
quoi cette période c'est quoi ces deux
là je suis moi tessinois d'accord un
soir je vais faire un plan pour ce bon
c'est bon voilà à blanc chez quelqu'un
on se connaissait pas il était 4 heures
du matin on fait ça un petit peu
rapidement n'est jamais très fier dans
ces moments là et évidemment il y avait
un colloque dont contre aby dans le noir
et tout ça tu y crois tu y crois pas je
me rhabille je repars quand j'arrive
chez moi c'était pas mes baskets c'était
les siennes et j'étais parti que son
portable
vous êtes repartis avec votre sexe on a
neuf
[Applaudissements]
merci oui mais ça le change des gens et
qui travaillait donc merci à vous merci
de